[Musique]
bonjour phrase le bon monsieur gbagbo jo
d'être candidat aux prochaines
législatives candidat dans la
circonscription du centre atlantique
tout à l'heure en faisant un recensement
à peu près une dizaine de candidats
pourquoi cette circonscription attire
attire-t-elle autant pas de bon mais
parce que il ya beaucoup de citoyens qui
sont en capacité de s'engager utilement
pour la défense des intérêts des
habitants de cette circonscription
personnellement je ne suis pas pour
qu'on taille par le bas plus il y aura
de candidats plus probablement le débat
sera riche et intéressant et donc chacun
fera ses preuves sur l'utile c'est
surtout parce qu'elle ferait de
marie-jeanne ne se représente pas moi je
ne me suis pas positionnés dans cette
optique là je ne me suis pas dit ça y
est
il n'y va plus j'y vais cela fait
qu'elles ont tant que je suis sur le
terrain cela fait très longtemps que
j'avais indiqué je le confirme
aujourd'hui je suis effectivement
candidat sur le centre atteint 7,7
inscription elle est plus ouverte que
les autres selon vous elle est peut-être
plus ouverte mais en tout cas c'est une
très belle circonscription avec des
communes qui sont extrêmement dynamiques
sur le plan économique je pense
singulièrement au lamentin je pense sont
robert mais avec aussi des problèmes
particuliers spécifiques notamment
l'agriculture je pense à des communes
comme le gone je pense à trinité où
effectivement les grandes productions à
faire face à des problèmes comme le
chlordécone
on y reviendra mais en face il ya quand
même de sérieux candidats josette manin
anciennes
présidente du conseil général il ya
aussi philippe edmond mariette qui
contamine la fonction puisqu'il était et
des députés
vous irez avec quels arguments face à de
telles personnalités
d'abord quand on fait de la politique on
ne se dit pas il y à des candidatures
plus de chance vous y aller parce que
vous avez la foi du charbonnier parce
que vous y croyez parce que vous
fréquentez le peut vous êtes avec le
peuple qui vous dit voilà il faut porter
cette parole a donc je suis dans une
démarche qui consiste à porter la parole
qui est la mienne parce que j'en
rencontre des gens parce qu'avec une
légende faite de socialisme avec une vga
tête de progressisme au sens où c'est
maintenant comme je disais surfer sur la
mode du progressisme le nombre de
maisons non non je ne suis pas un parti
bogui six en tout cas il est temps pour
cela je vous ai pu l'être sur la
présidentielle
le nom je veux opposer des valeurs de
progrès social notamment à une certaine
forme de conservatisme est de retour en
arrière et la situation actuelle s'y
prête parce que aujourd'hui vous avez
pour le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous avez de côté
quelques qui même si on n'est pas tout à
fait d'accord et personnellement je n'ai
pas été là qu avec le positionnement de
macro sur la réforme du code du travail
mais j'appelle à voter macron parce que
c'est lui le seul aujourd'hui en
capacité de battre marine le pen est ce
que vous êtes puisque si proche du
peuple que c'est la france le bon
justement vous entendez cette population
dire qu'il y en a vraiment mais elle ras
la casquette de certains discours qui
fait que 11 ans aux longs bas à droite à
gauche et puis finalement ayé pack
avance en paya mais je suis absolument
d'accord avec cette manière de voir les
choses c'est pour ça que j'ai pris mais
quand vous parlez du progressisme comme
ça non mais ce que le discours que tient
le peuple je l'entends je l'entend
partout effectivement ici en martinique
ont le sentiment que rien n'avance audi
convaincant si tel programme les choses
n'avancent pas on a mis des années des
années parce que les choses à voir ce
monsieur mais il faut que les choses
avancent
et pourquoi ce qu'elle avance je vous
pose la question ne faisait pas les
sentiments non c'est aussi le sens de
cette candidature
je n'ai pas le sens que les choses
avancent prodigieusement dans ce pays là
je n'ai pas non plus le sens que les
parlementaires actuels certaines autres
soient vigilants soit combatif au point
de se battre à paris pour obtenir des
résultats plus concrets
le député mode d'emploi selon vous ce
serait quoi c'est le député qui est à
l'écouté
ce député salle écoute ont surtout de
l'âge je prône l exemple les jeux covan
en ce tournant
oui je prends un exemple que j'ai cités
lorsque j'ai été interviewé sur ma
candidature
la relance de la filière bois le
gouvernement a lancé en jeu une filière
bois pour permettre précisément de la
construction d'immeubles en bois pour la
première fois en france à des hauteurs
extraordinaire bien il n'y a pas un seul
projet qui a été déposée par nous
trouver singulièrement pas en octobre et
si parfois d'avoir six parlementaires
qui siègent au sénat et à l'assemblée
l'a fait partie de ceux qui disent qu on
y voit pas on ne les entend pas il ne
circule pas assez dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée nationale au parlement je
fais partie de ceux qui disent que on
pourrait mieux faire qu'il faut être
parlementaire appelée temps et ne pas
faire autre chose je fais partie de ce
livre tous les candidats avant de avant
l'élection non mais il saura saisir
l'occasion sera plus présente
de tous les candidats monsieur lé temps
j'ai la chance d'avoir été assistant
parlementaire entre 86 et 88 90 à paris
j'ai la chance également d'être
l'assistant parlementaire de
parlementaires de kits à l'époque député
maire et nous avons été deux projets
bloqués
concernant vous par exemple tout à fait
la première cohabitation l'autre
l'assemblée nationale je n'y vais pas
pour découvrir
j ai travaillé tous les jours de 7
heures jusqu'à 22 heures le soin pendant
des années et avant beaucoup de ces
personnes qui prétendent connaître que
l'assemblée nationale françois bon votre
positionnement idéologique il faut quand
même
parlez vous arrive est très proche des
socialistes a même eu d investiture
socialiste aujourd'hui qu'en est il de
cette relation avec la fédération
socialiste de martinique
je rectifie monsieur vélo je n'ai jamais
été candidat du parti socialiste et non
non non j'ai été très proche comme jeu
j'ai été aussi membre fondateur de bâtir
vous le savez je n'ai jamais été
candidat du parti socialiste
en aucune circonstance à la baltique
j'étais très proche
c'est vrai du parti socialiste mais je
tiens ce que les choses soient claires
je ne suis pas le candidat du parti
socialiste
je ne suis pas au parti socialiste vous
n'avez pas eu envie d'avoir leur
investiture quand même pas du tout moi
je voudrais pas être candidat non non
non monsieur viol temps même après
raphaël vaugirard par exemple tous du
talent du tout pas du tout je n'ai pas
déposé de candidature il y avait le
dream est ouverte
je n'ai jamais obligé d'offre à tout
simplement non non non je n'ai pas
déposé de conduire l'homme de la rue de
services non mais pour que les choses
soient claires je n'ai pas été candidat
à la candidature
hello je ne me considère pas comme étant
candidat du parti socialiste du botté
par des personnes de la société civile
d'accord tout à l'heure j'ai dit mode
d'emploi pour le député aujourd'hui
qu'elle devrait être
quelles seraient vos priorités en tant
que députés élus pour cette
circonscription du centre authentique
vous feriez quoi pour non seulement des
sept circonscriptions des habitants de
cette circonscription et pour les
martiniquais quel type de loi vous
aimeriez voir discuter alors le travail
du parlementaire ça consiste à contrôler
le travail du gouvernement à poser des
questions à faire des interpellations
je pense que l'une des premières choses
que nous devrions soutenir
c'est par exemple faire en sorte que le
gouvernement qui va avoir la charge les
intérêts de la france puisse très
rapidement augmenté de façon
significative la retraite des personnes
âgées en tunique parce que c'est une
mesure qui est nécessaire parce
qu'aujourd'hui les personnes touchent
autour de 600 euros et chacun sait que
ça n'est pas possible de vivre d'un
autre pays
avec eux nous votre quête de 6 e ou est
ce que c'est le genre de discussion
qu'on peut avant très très vite sachant
que le futur président aurait une marge
de manoeuvre semble toute délicate
quel que soit celui qui sera désigné
dimanche soir oui j'entends bien que la
manoeuvre
la marge de manoeuvre du prochain
locataire de l'elysée sera transitoire
mais ce n'est pas parce que la situation
était si qu'il ne faut pas se battre
pour obtenir des choses bougent son
territoire est donc élu je me battrai
pour que sur ce point particulier pour
les personnes âgées
billy hayes résultats concrets nous
poser la question qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour la circonscription exemple en
matière de logement social et en matière
de logement tout coup je pense à une
mesure de parler plus longuement dans
les jours à venir
aujourd'hui vous pouvez défiscaliser
soit dans résidence seniors ou soit dans
des logements nos roues mais moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut faire une
proposition qui permet de croiser la
défiscalisation à la fois pour les
logements pour les seniors mais
également pour les logements libres de
telle manière que ça puisse booster le
développement économique de la
martinique parce que chacun sait que la
production entraîne derrière elle de
nouveaux emplois et la cie côté a besoin
et puis régler peut-être définitivement
cette question de l'indivision et régler
le problème de la division mais les
avocats de fort de france et il est muté
l'autre pays ont commencé toute une
série de conférences pour permettre aux
gens de sortir une proposition concrète
que je fais et je tends soutenir cette
proposition en matière de coopération
régionale également il y a des choses à
faire puisque par le passé nous avons
j'ai personnellement qualité de
président de l'aic soudaine qui dès la
première scène de la martinique
nous avions à l'époque signé un accord
de coopération avec monsieur kenyan tony
premier disque de cette lucie visant à
rénover la totalité de la capitale de
cette lui si ça a été combattue par
certains mais il faut pousser ça parce
que nous savons faire
il faut aussi accompagner les porteurs
de projets il faut accompagner ceux qui
ont un savoir faire qui peuvent
permettre de
vendre ce que la martinique s'est fait
très bien merci d'avoir été recto france
devant rappelle que vous êtes candidat
dans cette circonscription du centre
atlantique dix candidats à ce jour
recensé merci bonne journée
merci
[Musique]
d